dulces
hice un libro
hice un libro y digo hice porque no nada
más lo escribí ese es el punto
interesante no nada más soy el autor
además de escribirlo
yo hice la revisión y la corrección de
textos además de eso yo mismo lo diseñé
por si fuera poco yo hice y seguí muy de
cerca el registro de la marca como tal y
de los contenidos anti indautor fui con
el proveedor de papel y escogí el papel
que quería para la portada y para los
interiores compre ese papel y se lo
llevé a la imprenta platiqué con la
imprenta y le dije exactamente cómo
quería que se imprimirá fui autorizando
cada uno de los procesos y me dejaron
entrar a las máquinas salí a la portada
con el foro la autorizaba salían los
interiores los autorizaba además de eso
cuando estuvieron listos fui a la
imprenta cargar las cajas las subí a mi
carro no me ayudaron y las llevé a mi
oficina
organice las presentaciones de mi libro
digo presentaciones porque tiene ya dos
partes ahorita vemos es la primera
presentación de mi libro
en ella invite a 26 artistas visuales de
monterrey a que interpretarán contenido
en mi libro e hicieran piezas relativas
a eso y fue también una exposición
además en esa en esa presentación
se sumaron marcas de alcohol obviamente
para tener una una buena presentación
este
cerveza y mezcal nos faltaba fue en la
en el lugar de un amigo y se juntaron
unas 200 personas un poco más estaba muy
bien hasta que llegó la policía porque
creo que a los vecinos no les gustó y
bueno esta es la segunda presentación ya
fue más pacífica
yo mismo también
he organizado la venta del libro el
libro lo puse una plataforma online para
venderlo a todo méxico y luego lo que
hice fue un sistema para poder vender el
libro fuera de librerías que cesc
entonces a mis amigos de los lugares que
frecuentó primero les dije vamos a
vender el libro pues sí entonces el
libro primero con amigos y negocios de
conocidos y después con gente que se fue
sumando así el libro se ha vendido o se
vende en mares obviamente se vende en
restaurantes en peluquerías en centros
de yoga lugares de nutrición ese se
vende incluso en una tienda que se
dedique a hacer artículos de piel
- team texas se vende en una tienda que
vende artículos mexicanos y hace tortas
y tacos en nueva york y ellos lo
distribuyen a todo a todo eeuu entonces
no necesitan las librerías
yo mismo también abril a mis redes
sociales mis redes sociales en las
cuales yo genero los contenidos y yo
obviamente contestó todo lo que me
mandan cuando no se van de no deseado
porque lo verse a uno de no deseado y no
y los que ya no responda ante estar pero
bueno yo genero todo eso y nunca ha
invertido en publicidad para mi libro y
en redes sociales ni en ninguna otra
cosa y tengo una cantidad de followers
orgánica que cualquier aspirante a
influencer juvenil envidiaría la verdad
la mejor forma de publicidad de mi libro
ha sido el boca a boca y el publicación
la publicación es gente que lo está
haciendo suyo y lo publica de una manera
honesta
además de eso
todos los días
todos y cada uno de los días de los días
en mi oficina yo mismo
empaquetó los libros que se van a que va
a llegar la mensajería por ellos que el
proceso ya lo tengo súper regulado
entonces me mandan las guías las imprimo
veo cuántos libros on anoto cuántos
libros son lo meto en un sobre cierro
grapo hago un
aún así este y luego los se los entregó
al de mensajería que amablemente llega
todos los días a repartir libros a todo
méxico esto apareciera así contado que
soy como un monstruo de múltiples
cabezas que echa fuego
y más o menos pero no es tan así es más
bien como un monstruo de estas este de
caricatura que son buenos donde yo soy
una cabeza y las demás cabezas son todas
las personas que de una u otra manera se
han sumado en lugar de estar echando
fuego de champú roloff puro corazoncito
este va desde las personas desde mi
familia mis amigos y el abogado que me
ha ayudado con esto los que han metido
en su lugar el libro en los que lo han
comprado los que lo han publicado
entonces si es un monstruo bueno de
caricatura echando corazoncito de estar
echando por un me encanta así como
cuando le dan y lo salen todos los
corazoncitos andando
mis libros se llaman las cosas pasan por
algo o no y las cosas pasan por algo o
no
round de la pelea para él para el
segundo libro y juntos
de manera independiente auto publicada
tienen al menos ocho mil copias
distribuidas entre méxico estados unidos
y sabrá
donde más porque hay gente que lo manda
por otro lado yo todavía no este libro
su descripción está en la en la primera
hoja reflexiones pensamientos y
para enfrentar la vida por alan dávila
y de eso se trata sombras él es mi
abuelo mi abuelo tenía un este truco que
se pone una cucharada sopera aquí este
una cuchara para cocinar y lo que hacía
era dejarla quieta equilibrar la pienso
mucho que está ahí en el primer libro
esa foto porque pienso que la vida trata
mucho de eso es ese juego de equilibrar
entre los chingon y los culeros
y de eso va mi libro tiene frases que
que de una manera y con un lenguaje con
un lenguaje directo te cuestionan y te
dicen a ver las cosas pasan por algo o
no cuestiona te todo va a estar mejor o
no todo estar mal también entonces por
eso estamos equilibrando entre los
chicos y lo son frases que
celebran los chingón y frases que te
dicen lo malo existe y cómo le hacemos
para enfrentarlo hay que hay que
celebrar las dos cosas y hay que aceptar
que las dos cosas conviven
mi libro es un libro punta de ahí
partimos el punto es más que peinados o
qué ropa el punto si lo quisiéramos
definir desde el punto de vista musical
sería muy difícil porque a lo largo de
su historia de su nacimiento a finales
de los setentas
ha variado mucho y se han de tener
dentro del mismo punto se han generado
pues diferentes en movimientos entonces
pero hay dos características que han
prevalecido a lo largo de la historia
del punto de los setentas hasta acá una
es cuestionar lo establecido y otra es
la ética del hazlo tú mismo entonces por
eso y ahorita lo diré más a fondo pero
mi libro es un libro punto el punto que
cuando la gente te dice no lo intentes
en casa advertencia guardia no intentes
en casa el punto dice inténtalo en casa
hazlo en casa no te quedes ahí el pum
cuestiona te cuestiona por qué y hace
algo al respecto
el punto es una necesidad de expresión
un empoderamiento personal para que se
dé un empoderamiento grupal y así el
movimiento punto que hace que nazca que
haya generación de movimiento y este
empoderamiento personal y grupal en la
moda por ejemplo reinterpretando como se
ponían a pablo de los setentas cuando
nacía cómo se usaban ciertas prendas con
un safety ping la rompió y luego la
vuelva a unir por ejemplo así nacen
bandas de punk que están que son parte
de la historia musical y ojo muchos de
esas bandas nos
que no es necesario saber tocar los
instrumentos con con mucha habilidad o
saber cantar así nacen bandas como como
ramones así nacen bandas como sex
pistols donde dicen lo que importa es
que quieras hacer la banda y luego ya
ahí vamos que se han podido meter en la
en la escena musical o hay un ejemplo en
1976 los busco pge en 76 cuando no
tenemos todo lo que teníamos lo que
tenemos ahora hacen su propio disco y lo
distribuyen por correo y lo promocionan
por medio de fans sin que las otras el
movimiento en diseño y lo y lo
promocionan también por medio por medio
de él boca a boca y por medio de pósters
mi libro es un libro porque porque tiene
este mismo sistema lo que pasa es que
cuando yo es que escribió el libro que
la forma de escribirlo es que tenía una
libreta por tres años y una pluma iba
escribiendo iba escribiendo francés
hasta que llegue el punto que dije voy a
hacer un libro y luego se lo llevó o
diop dije se lo voy a compartir
editoriales que me gustan porque
editores que me gustan lo primero es que
la mayoría se es editorial
dice contáctanos es muchas gracias por
el momento no estamos recibiendo
manuscritos ok sido entonces y la otra
es que a las que si se les podía
contactar pues pasó esto y pasó como
cuando le mandas un mensaje a la que te
gusta y luego nada más te deja en zinc
con las dos palomitas
entonces yo dije a ver qué voy a hacer
voy a voy a dejar aquí mi necesidad de
expresión
me voy me voy a esperar expresar
o esperar
no sé expresar y así es como el libro el
libro nace el libro no empezó con estos
ocho mil copias primero en cien copias
que dije son sin copias a ver qué
piensan de él y lo voy a regalar todas a
100 amigos entonces lo único el único
punto aquí es que no tenía cien amigos
no tengo cien amigos para repartirles
cien copias entonces lo que hizo fue que
repartí 40.40 iba más o menos
como como en los otros 60 se empezaron a
distribuir entre personas que no conocía
lo empezaron a ser viral se empezó a
publicar a compartir y ahí fue donde
empezó todo este movimiento de pura
gente bien padre apoyando de corazón un
proyecto que nace así entonces si yo no
hubiera hecho esto en lugar de decir
hice un libro les estaría diciendo tenía
una idea para un libro y si les dijera
yo tenía una idea para un libro pues me
convertiría en uno más de las personas
que son puro pedo
y yo no quería ser europeo porque ser
próspero es callar tu necesidad de
expresión
el punto acá es que pues entonces cómo
le hago de hecho se me han acercado a lo
largo de estudia como lago para publicar
el libro gente con con su ya ya esté
terminado su libro oye cómo le hago y me
los encuentro después de un año hoy
entonces como le hago un niño la verdad
mi consejo es sólo pinches hazlo
sácale copias grapa los por el medio
entregárselo a tu familia y diles que
qué opinan no no tienes para copias no
quieres gastar en copias a lo digital
sube un pdf y comparte se lo al mundo
solo pinches hazlo por eso yo les digo
que que si fueras pong pues ya hubiera
publicado un libro lo que estamos
hablando perfectamente pero también yo
hubiera grabado tu podcast
si fueras punk en realidad ya hubiera
abierto tu café también o ya hubiera
sacado tu marca de ropa o si fueras punt
ya hubiera empezado a hacerlo realidad
de neta no nada más lo voy a contar si
fueras punk
pues ya hubiera encendido la chispa como
ese lema aquí aunque yo le agregaría que
con la chispa por la chispa no más no
nos alcanza
o sea como dijo la como dijo
la canción manténlo prendido fuego o sea
esto no es de esto no ando más de chispa
yo los quiero invitar a retomar la la
ética punta para sus proyectos creo que
es importante en estas épocas donde
estamos siempre esperando a que pase
algo más para ello hacer las cosas si
junto mil likes público mi libro
meta entonces debemos de retomar eso
porque lo a veces pensamos sabes que es
que no te preocupes tienes toda la vida
para publicarlo pues no tienes toda la
vida ella ya te gastas de una gran parte
hay una hay una frase la frase de mi
primer libro que es mi favorita que dice
la vida se pasa en es estúpido
no habla de que la vida se pase en
que que si no haces algo por ella
y se te va a ir y en mi segundo libro
hay esto con lo que quiero cerrar mi
invitación para ustedes
no tienes toda la vida
no tienes toda la vida para hacer tus
proyectos retoma la ética
hazlo sólo pinchando porque como dice
la última frase del round 2
bien
y al y al final te mueres gracias
[Aplausos]